hi wir sind wieder für euch ZDF heute
live ganz herzlich willkommen bei uns im
Stream schön dass ihr bei uns seid und
sorry ganz kurz an der Stelle für die
leichte Verspätung wir hatten noch ein
paar technische Probleme unser Thema
heute das ist die russische Propaganda
in Deutschland wir wollen euch heute
zeigen wie sie uns manipulieren soll wo
sie verfängt aber auch wie wir uns davor
schützen können das erklärt uns heute
vor allem unsere Expertin das ist Pia
lamberti vom Center für Monitoring
Analyse und Strategie kurz cemas sie
forscht seit Jahren zu Fake News und
auch zu verschwörungsmythen und außerdem
bei uns in der Sendung ein Interview mit
Vera jurowa sie ist Vizepräsidentin der
Europäischen Kommission und sie hat da
vor allen Dingen den Schwerpunkt auf der
Bekämpfung von Fake News mit ihr
sprechen wir aber darüber warum das
EU-Verbot vom russischen
propaganda-institution wie Sputnik oder
RT leicht Umgang werden kann
was sind eure Fragen was sind eure
Meinungen was beschäftigt euch zu diesem
Thema stellt die gerne direkt in die
Chats oder per Mailadresse seht ihr ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de ich werde also viel
wie möglich versuchen weiterzuleiten an
unsere Expertin Pia lamberti und die
wird die Fragen auch sicher sehr gerne
beantworten und jetzt gehen wir auch
direkt rüber zu ihr da haben wir sie
Frau lamberti schönen guten Abend
erstmal danke für Ihre Zeit einen
schönen guten Abend Frau lamberti sie
haben Anfang November mit cemas eine
Studie herausgegeben die zeigt dass pro
russische verschwörungsmythen in
Deutschland bzw die Akzeptanz und der
Glaube daran im Vergleich vom April bis
jetzt zugenommen hat welchen Anstieg
haben Sie da genau herausgefunden und
warum schafft es Russland dass diese
Mythen hier offenbar immer weiter
geglaubt werden
wir haben in unserer Studie verschiedene
narrative verschwörungserzählung aber
auch propagandistische Aussagen
abgefragt die erste Studie war im
Frühjahr jetzt noch mal im Herbst eine
weitere nachfolgestudie und was man eben
da sieht ist dass es zu einer Zunahme
auf ja leider allen Aussagen die wir uns
angeschaut hat gekommen ist das
beispielsweise Menschen glauben die NATO
hätte Russland so lange provoziert bis
sie einmarschieren mussten da waren wir
bei 12% im April 18 % im Oktober und was
nicht nur zugenommen hat ist die direkte
Zustimmung sondern auch tatsächlich der
Teils teilsbereich der Teilzeitbereich
ist empirische mal ein bisschen
schwierig zu handeln wer sind diese
Menschen das versucht man schon lange
herauszufinden ich würde aber schon
sagen dass das so eine Art Resonanzboden
ist auf dem auch russische
Desinformation fallen kann wenn Menschen
verunsichert sind sind sie in ihrem
Verhalten anders das wissen wir auch aus
der Forschung Beispiel diverse zu
corona-verschwörungserzählung wer mit
diesen verschwörungserzählung
konfrontiert ist wird verunsichert ist
dann weniger bereit sich zum Beispiel
impfen zu lassen und das spielt
natürlich hier dann auch noch mal eine
Rolle und welche Mittel russland
versucht einzusetzen um in diese
Verunsicherungen reinzugehen das schauen
wir uns jetzt an an einem Beispiel der
den ganzen propaganda-apparat Stützen
soll das ist der Staat Sender Russia
Today der hat auch ein Ableger in
Deutschland rt.de und wie diese Apparat
funktioniert das zeigt uns jetzt Thomas
Gonsior mit Aussagen und Ausschnitten
aus der ZDF Zoom Dokumentation Russlands
deutsche Propaganda Krieger
2016 in Berlin demonstrieren Russen und
der Kreml ist dabei dabei in Form des
staatssenders RT dessen Mission
vermeintlicher Aufklärung über
angebliche westliche Lügen
stehen die machen den Medien Lügerei die
Äußerungen dieses Demonstranten offenbar
ganz im Sinne der rt-reporterin
ich danke dir für deine Unterstützung
Unterstützung angeblich für die Wahrheit
beispielsweise über Corona die hört sich
dann 2020 auf RT so an
einige ukrainische Experten und
Anwohnern bringen die Ausbrüche in der
Krankheiten der letzten Jahre in den
zahlreichen ukrainischen Städten mit der
wachsenden Anzahl der amerikanischen
biolaboratorin in der Ukraine in
Zusammenhang
geheime bio-labors also die USA der
Westen seien schuld ein hauptnarrativ
des auslandssenders der wurde 2005 vom
russischen Staat gegründet heißt es
Russia Today dann RT das Ziel gibt der
Präsident selbst vor
wir versuchen was ich betone das Monopol
der angelsächsischen Medien zerbrechen
[Musik]
2014 kommt der Sender nach Deutschland
empfangbar über Satellit und online im
vergangenen März verbietet die
EU-Kommission die Verbreitung seiner
Inhalte EU-weite sendesperre wegen des
russischen Überfalls auf die Ukraine
dennoch wer will kann RT Deutsch immer
noch empfangen Suchmaschinen finden die
neue leicht geänderte Web-Adresse
RT sendet weiter verbreitet Propaganda
und so sagen Insider führt Krieg mit
Bildern und mit Worten
ja warum gelingt es Russlands dieses
EU-Verbot so leicht zu umgehen und was
plant die EU darüber hinaus um die
desinformationsstrategie Russlands
aufzuhalten dabei konnten wir vor der
Sendung mit Vera jurowa sprechen sie ist
Vizepräsidentin der Europäischen
Kommission und sie hat er unter anderem
den Schwerpunkt auf der Bekämpfung von
Fake News
guten Abend Frau Jehova
guten Abend was macht es eigentlich
persönlich mit Ihnen wenn ich Ihnen sage
und wenn wir auch hören dass Inhalte von
RT rtde 8 Monate nach dem Verbot der
EU-Kommission immer noch auffindbar sind
[Musik]
ja von uns bewertet und wir haben das
als eine Waffe Putins definiert und
wir haben das nicht als Medium
wahrgenommen dass innerhalb der EU
geschützt werden soll und aus diesem
Grund haben wir die schwierige
Entscheidung getroffen Wascher today und
Sputnik auf die Sanktionsliste zu setzen
da sie natürlich hier als
kriegs-propaganda eingesetzt wurden
absolut nur nach diesem Verbot ist es
aktuell immer noch so das haben sie ja
im März getroffen dass die Inhalte durch
z.B sogenannte spiegelseiten oder VPN
Tunnel immer noch ja verfügbar sind und
immer noch Millionen Menschen erreichen
also noch mal die Frage wie geht's Ihnen
persönlich damit das Verbot beschlossen
zu haben aber jetzt eben noch
festzustellen die Inhalte sind noch
offenbar
wissen Sie dass es doch die gleiche
Situation auch mit allen anderen
Umgehungen der Sanktionen wir müssen
alles tun was uns möglich ist um das zu
kontrollieren und wir müssen hier
natürlich auch die Verbreitung von
Nachrichten auf Russia Today verhindern
und wenn es das immer noch gibt dann
verstößt man natürlich auch gegen die
Zahlen das Sperren von RT z.B auch auf
YouTube oder auch das Verbot schon die
Reichweite eingeschränkt hat auf der
anderen Seite gibt es aber auch
unabhängige Recherchen vom Netzwerk
Korrektiv hier in Deutschland die sagen
eben noch einmal dass er TDE einfach
dutzende sogenannte spiegelseiten
erstellt hat also einfach Webseiten mit
leicht veränderte Adresse und auch die
VPN Tunnel hatte ich gerade angesprochen
da wird er sogar damit dass man das
einfach so machen soll um weiter auf die
Desinformationen
zugreifen zu können das heißt also
nochmal bis heute erreichen diese
Informationen diese Fake News Millionen
Menschen mir stellt sich die Frage hat
dann das EU-Verbot genug gebracht
wir haben getan was wir tun mussten wir
haben diese Sanktionen beschlossen und
jetzt ist es an den Organen die Dinge zu
kontrollieren und entsprechend zu
reagieren wenn man sieht dass die
Sanktion nicht erfolgreich sind ich habe
beispielsweise vor kurzem mit den Google
Managern gesprochen und habe mich mit
ihnen über Youtube unterhalten und das
ist ja nicht direkt Wascher today aber
auch dort gibt es ja das Gebot das
entsprechend zu behandeln in Bezug auf
die Inhalte da geht es um andere Namen
und dort wird es publiziert und wir
wollen natürlich dass er jeder sich an
dieser Maßnahmen hält wir wollen ja ganz
präzise vorgehen und wir wollen hier
auch auf die Inhalte Aktien wir wollen
ja auch den Ursprung der Inhalte treffen
um den Inhalt nicht verfügbar zu machen
die Videos nicht verfügbar zu machen
aber es ist Prinzip als ob man die Flut
mit Händen aufhalten möchte man wird die
absoluten
Situation
Gegebenheiten nicht immer sehen können
also wenn diese Inhalte vollständig
entfernt sein werden von all diesen
Orten aber wir müssen weiter daran
arbeiten da das ja eine sehr ernste
Angelegenheit ist wir wurden ja
kritisiert in Bezug auf die Sanktionen
gegenüber Sputnik und Wasser today und
wir bewerten ja auch immer wieder neue
sogenannten Medien die im Prinzip
wirklich nur russische Propaganda
Instrumente sind und wir schauen uns
diese an wir treffen Entscheidungen und
wir erwarten natürlich auch dass diese
Sanktion vollständig verfolgt werden und
jemand wird natürlich das ganze auch
nachverfolgen und wir werden uns darum
kümmern dass diese toxischen Inhalte in
den
Europe verfügbar sind alles machen was
sie unternehmen mit wem sie sich
unterhalten zum Beispiel mit Google aber
fühlen sie sich dann habe ich so ein
bisschen raus gehört nicht eigentlich
ohnmächtig wenn dann die diese
Information auch noch bei Google
aufzufinden sind also reichen die Mittel
der EU da an dieser Stelle wie fühlen
sie sich damit
nein wir haben getan was wir tun mussten
wir haben diese sehr schwierige
Entscheidung getroffen und jetzt ist es
an denjenigen die den Medienmarkt
beobachten jetzt müssen diese
garantieren dass diese Sanktionen auch
respektiert werden es gibt natürlich
immer noch sehr viel Arbeit gerade in
Bezug auf die Gegebenheiten aber ich
fühle mich überhaupt nicht ohnmächtig
das ist nicht das wie ich mich fühle ich
kann in das genau ist andersherum sagen
ich habe ja in Deutschland auch oft
gehört dass wir unsere Kompetenzen
überschritten haben das wäre Schritte
gegen die Medien ergriffen haben aber
wir müssen uns allen ganz bewusst machen
dass es jetzt an der Zeit ist die Dinge
ist als das zu benennen was sie sind und
wasche today und
andere sind ja Sanktionen unterworfen
worden und das sind in keinster Weise
Medien und müssen
meiner Seite höre ich da eine Kritik
auch an Deutschland und an die
Bundesregierung raus in Sachen Umsetzung
ich kritisiere die Organe die nicht
vollständig ihre Arbeit machen bei der
Bewertung des Medienmarktes bei der
Ergreifung von Schritten
gegen die Medien die ja zum Teil
sanktioniert worden es geht nicht um
eine Kritik an Deutschland das geht
darum dass wir in allen Mitgliedstaaten
die Lücken schließen müssen wir müssen
die Funktion Umsetzen der deutschen
Bundesregierung auch diese Organe zu
kontrollieren und deren Arbeit wir sehen
mit gerade Blick auf Deutschland dass es
an technischen Know-How auch fehlt diese
diese EU-Verbot durchzusetzen wir hören
auch davon den unabhängigen Recherchen
von Korrektiv dass die die Bildung
dieser spiegelseiten nur in
unregelmäßigen Abständen überwacht wird
was kann die EU da tun um technisches
Know-how und auch eine Regelmäßigkeit in
diese Überprüfungen ja weiter
einzuführen
was kann die EU tun ja wenn wir sehen
dass das Gesetz nicht befolgt wird wenn
wir sehen dass ein Staat bestimmte Dinge
nicht tun dann können wir die Prozedere
in Kraft setzen die hier notwendig sind
aber hier sind wir nicht an diesem Punkt
wo es beispielsweise um Sanktionen gehen
könnte hier geht es wirklich darum dass
wir jeden bewegen müssen die Arbeit
durchzuführen da ist wirklich um sehr
sehr viel geht es sind sehr schwierige
Entscheidungen und
wir müssen hier alle Organe betrachten
und das sind ja unabhängige Organe die
den Medienmarkt bewerten und die die
Arbeit machen müssen Aspekt sagen einige
IT-Experten auch Medienrechtler das ist
nie Zitat eine gute Idee sei
gesellschaftliche Probleme wie wir es
haben mit technischen Mitteln lösen zu
wollen sie sagen stattdessen setzt
lieber auf Fakten setzt auf Projekte die
die Demokratie stärken tut die EU das
stärkt sie Projekte die mit Fakten gegen
dieses gesellschaftliches Problem
Vorgehen
wer unterstützen natürlich viele
Projekte zur Demokrat demokratiebildung
wir haben unterschiedliche Programme wir
haben spezialisierte Programme wir haben
hier ein Programm das sich natürlich
auch mit der Geschäfte der
EU-Mitgliedstaaten beschäftigt das geht
hier natürlich auch um die Geschichte im
20 Jahrhundert hier geht es darum die
Fehler der Vergangenheit nicht zu
wiederholen es geht ja darum dass man
vor Augen führt dass gefährliche
Situation noch einmal auftreten können
ist immer gut in die Vergangenheit zu
blicken und wir
geben auch sehr viele Mittel in die
Mitgliedstaaten um in Bildung zu
investieren um kulturelle Programmen und
hier geht es natürlich nicht nur um die
junge Generation sondern hier geht es um
ein Verständnis für die gemeinsame
Geschichte es geht um das Verständnis
unserer Werte die wir schützen müssen
wir tun viel und da möchte ich Ihnen
eine user-frage Stellen vor jurowa von
Maria Johann sie sagt ich möchte die
russische Sichtweise gern selbst lesen
das vor Boot von RT so sagt sie sei
Zensur nimm die Bürger können sich Ihre
Meinung selbst bilden haben Sie
Verständnis dafür
ich glaube das habe ich bereits
beantwortet wir mussten reagieren
die russische Propaganda ist ein
waffeninstrument auf dem Gebiet der
Europäischen Union und wir haben
verstanden dass das nicht einfach so
weitergehen kann das war eine ganz neue
Qualität und auch vor der Invasion haben
wir ja gesehen
wo es hingeht wir haben gesehen dass wir
verstärkt russischer Propaganda
russischen jazzinformationen und
russischen Cyberangriffen ausgesetzt
waren und das waren ja ganz neue
Bedrohungen und das war natürlich auch
Teil der russischen militärischen
Doktrinen und wir haben versucht das mit
traditionelleren Methoden
zu lösen aber nach dem Angriff mussten
wir natürlich auch zu mehr Schritten
greifen es war eine ganz neue Intensität
das Blatt hatte sich total gewendet und
wir dürfen auch
die Wirkung von Desinformationen auf
unsere Gesellschaften nicht
unterschätzen das ist etwas was
maßgeschneidert wird von Russland in
Bezug auf unsere Gesellschaften denn es
geht hier um das Untergraben der
Unterstützung in unserer Gesellschaft in
Bezug auf die Ukraine man will dafür
sorgen dass es keine Unterstützung mehr
gibt für die Ukraine keine militärische
Unterstützung und das kann eine sehr
mächtige Waffe in den Händen Putins sein
wenn wir nicht entsprechend reagieren
Dankeschön Frau Jehova für das Gespräch
herzlichen Dank
das Gespräch haben wir vor der Sendung
aufgezeichnet und auch aus technischen
Gründen teilweise gekürzt
wieder rüber zu Frau lamberti von cemas
Roller Betty wir haben das gehört vor
jurowa und die EU sagen wir haben das
Verbot beschlossen jetzt gilt es dass
die Mitgliedsländer das Umsetzen klingt
so ein bisschen wie auch wegschieben der
Verantwortung was ist aus ihrer Sicht
nötig dass dieses Verbot noch mehr seine
Wirksamkeit auch entfaltet
ja man steht hier tatsächlich ja vor der
Herausforderung
wie man schnell genug reagieren kann das
hatte sie ja gerade auch schon genannt
es gibt spiegelseiten dann werden neue
erstellt das ist tatsächlich gar nicht
so einfach trotzdem wäre es eben wichtig
zeitnahmer zu reagieren die Recherche
die Sie gerade auch von kurativ zitiert
haben zusammen mit dem eisd zeigt ja
dass das Wissen da ist welche
spiegelseiten es gibt das heißt man
könnte die Unternehmen aber das wird
natürlich das Problem nicht in Gänze
lösen ich glaube wir müssen uns
insgesamt von der Idee verabschieden das
eine Maßnahme alleine die
Desinformationen und deren Wirkung
eindämmen kann sondern das muss immer
eine Kombination aus vielen
verschiedenen Punkten sein welche
Maßnahmen sehen Sie da auch vielleicht
von Seiten der EU
also ich denke es ist gut wenn man
versucht sich das systematisch
vorzustellen also wie können wir vor
einer
Desinformationskampagne wenn man das
jetzt einfach mal so prototypisch
durchdenkt Menschen stärken die können
wir Prävention betreiben da gibt es
Medienbildung Angebote da kann man sich
aber auch noch mal mit demokratischen
Prozessen mit ja Selbstwirksamkeit
auseinandersetzen was machen wir wenn es
denn zu so einer Verbreitung kommt also
ähm da gibt es kleine Möglichkeit man
stellt Warnungen aus ne das ähm eben
noch mal vorsichtiger sein soll das kann
auch schon Effekt haben dann geht's
natürlich auch teilweise darum schnell
zu reagieren Dinge zu aufzulösen wenn
absolut cool falsch Behauptung kommen
und danach kommt natürlich erstmal meine
journalistische Aufarbeitung eine
juristische und ich denke die Rolle der
EU sollte vor allem darin liegen diese
Komponenten zu stärken ich bin davon
überzeugt dass Kampf gegen
Desinformationen erstmal ja vor allem
von der Zivilgesellschaft von
Journalismus getragen sein sollte weil
natürlich dieser Begriff immer wieder
auch gerne instrumentalisiert wird wenn
man am Beispiel Türkei sind
bleiben wir dann noch mal ganz kurz bei
den Aussagen von Frau jurowa sie
beschreiben auch die EU sollte mehr
verstärkt auf die Stärkung von
demokratieprojekten legen reichen Ihnen
da die Ankündigung die Frau Jever heute
gemacht hat mit wir machen das ja schon
und wir unterstützen das ja schon müsste
da nicht eigentlich noch mehr und was
konkreter auch beschlossen werden
also es ist schon mehr passiert man muss
schon sagen dass das Thema
Desinformation jetzt auch ein ganz
anderen Level diskutiert wird als es
noch vor dem 24 Februar der Fall ist das
Problem ist eben dass natürlich auch
Anträge auf EU-Ebene sehr komplex sind
das überfordert dann wahrscheinlich vor
allem kleine Organisation die diesen
Aufwand diesen bürokratischen und dann
nicht unbedingt stemmen können und auch
in Deutschland ist die Fördersituation
ja immer noch sehr projektgebunden dann
teilweise eben ja auch im fördern
eingebunden und ich denke das ist gerade
auch ab Februar dann noch mal mehr
unbürokratische Fördermöglichkeiten
gebraucht hätte ihm um auf diese neue
Lage eingehen zu können und diese
Herausforderungen sind ja jetzt auch
nicht weg wenn man jetzt auf die
nächsten Monate schaut blicke ich da
auch schon mit Sorge drauf
also da auf jeden Fall auch die
Verantwortung das weiter voranzutreiben
eine wichtige Rolle
nebeninstitutionen wie Russia Today die
den Propagandaapparat stützen sollen
sind ja auch
influencerin und influencer die die
Botschaften im unter dem Deckmantel des
Kremls verbreiten sollen in der ZDF
zoom-doku Russlands deutsche Propaganda
Krieger da wurden auch Aussagen von zum
Beispiel Alina Lipp und Serge vilbert
analysiert und wir hören jetzt mal
gemeinsam in Aussagen von diesen
influencerinnen
die Menschen
die die ukrainischen Nazis an ihnen
die Russen nehmen gerade ganz platt
gesagt den Nazis die Waffen weg in China
Fragen oder im in Indien dann sagen sie
ja die haben die gleiche Meinung das
Westen hat Russland provoziert hat zwei
Brüder Volker erstmal im Ukraine auf
sich aufeinandergesetzt dass sie sich
töten übrigens das Töten von in diesem
Bürgerkrieg haben nicht die Don jetzt da
und nicht nur Menschen begann sondern
ukrainische Einheiten und die Nazis
wie ordnen Sie diese Aussagen diese
Rhetorik dieser russischen influencer
ein und wie gefährlich sind sie auch
also gerade Alina Lipp hat tatsächlich
seit Beginn des russischen
Angriffskrieges in einschlägigen Räumen
also insbesondere auch telegram eine
große Reichweite aufbauen können vorher
war sie relativ unbedeutend sie hatte da
auch schon versucht irgendwie Fuß zu
fassen im Milieu das hatte vorher nicht
so gut geklappt und sie inszeniert sich
ja auch sehr häufig als so eine Art ja
friedensjournalistin Begriff den Sie
über sich nutzt eine junge Frau die eben
die Wahrheit komplett verdreht die ja
auch nicht nur nach Deutschland sendet
sondern die berichtet ja immer auf
Deutsch und auf Russisch wird auch in
Russland eingeladenen Talkshows ich
finde das schon sehr gefährlich eben
weil sie russische Propaganda noch mal
wirklich stark verbreitet gesehen das
auch in unseren Analysen dass Ihre Post
teilweise alleine auf telegram eine
halbe Million News erlangen das ist
schon relativ viel für da
eine user-frage kommt noch mal zu dem
Komplex zu Russia Today von
wanderlustiger bei Youtube er fragt sich
warum darf ich keinen RT lesen warum hat
man Angst gerade das verbieten macht die
Seite überhaupt zu interessant sagt er
für verschwörungssuchende ich fand die
Seite das ist seine Meinung immer gut
zuschauen wie der Russe tickt vielleicht
ordnen Sie Frau lamberti da noch mal die
Gefährlichkeit dieser Seite ein
also erstmal ist es natürlich keine
einfache Entscheidung zu sagen man sagt
zu mir eine journalistisches Medium das
kann ja finde ich auch durch dass ich
diese Entscheidung nicht einfach gemacht
wurde weil er hat hier die handelt es
sich aber nicht um ein journalistisches
Medium sondern um Staatspropaganda das
ist noch mal ein Unterschied den ich
auch sehr sehr wichtig in dieser
Markierung findet und wir haben es eben
mit einer Seite zu tun die ja auch vor
dem 24 februar eine große Reichweite
hatte die in Deutschland immer wieder
auch Rechtsextreme Position verbreitet
hat das stimmungsmacht und hätte
verbreitet hat und dementsprechend war
sie gefährlich und der Zugang ist eben
jetzt erschwert ich finde das richtig
wie gesagt das macht würde ich bei
vielen anderen Fällen auch anders sehen
aber gerade er TDI war immer schon da
zentral und hat da schon immer
mitgemischt weil seitdem sie eben in
Deutschland da aktiv waren bei der
Verbreitung von Herzen
von der Betty eine weitere Frage von
Stefan s die zielt so ein bisschen auch
gleich auf die Studienergebnisse die sie
gemeinsam für den November rausgefunden
haben da schauen wir gleich drauf die
user-frage ist
generell da fragt sich der User Stefan
ich frage mich Zitat bei wem diese
Manipulation allen Ernstes funktioniert
was sind das für Leute
ja das also es gibt schon
gesellschaftliche Gruppen in denen sich
diese negative stärker verfestigen ganz
klassisch sieht man das bei WählerInnen
der AFD gefolgt von WählerInnen der
linke da ist schon immer noch ein
Abstand zwischen aber dennoch sind das
die Gruppen die am empfängnissten dafür
sind im Osten sehen wir höhere
Zustimmungswerte als im Westen und dann
muss man natürlich immer auch noch mal
so ein bisschen unterscheiden das eine
sind so propagandistische aber das
Information kann ja zum Beispiel auch
ähm Chaos erzeugen wollen ne da wird
dann behauptet es gibt zum Beispiel kein
Benzin mehr und selbst wenn man sonst
vielleicht nicht anfällig ist glaubt man
das dann wenn man oder wenn man sieht
das andere zur Tankstelle gehen und dann
Benzin erfüllen dann freut man den
vielleicht einfach und nehmen den
Menschen die das Glauben gibt es aber
auch viele die sich verunsichert lassen
und auch das ist ein Erfolg im Sinne der
Desinformationen im Sinne der Propaganda
und da ist Gruppe schon viel viel größer
und gar nicht mehr so klar
differenzierbar dann schauen wir doch
mal uns anhand von zwei Beispielen von
verschwörungsmythen an die Zahlen die
Sie beschrieben haben was sich da in
ihrer Studie auch erkennen lässt die
befragten sie haben die Befragten
gebeten zum Beispiel sich zu der Aussage
zu positionieren die Nato hat Russland
so lange provoziert dass Russland in den
Krieg ziehen musste 19 Prozent der
Befragten haben diese Aussage zugestimmt
16% 60% lehnten sie ab auffällig ist
aber dass der Anteil derer die da
Aussage zustimmen im Osten doppelt so
hoch ist wie der im Westen wie sind
diese Zahlen Frau lamberti zu erklären
und was lesen Sie auch daraus
ja also insgesamt war es so in den
letzten Jahren dass der Unterschied im
verschwörungsglaube zwischen Ost und
West zurückgegangen ist der war
tatsächlich bei der letzten mittelstudie
bei der ich mitgewirkt habe vor Corona
nicht mehr existent in dem Moment wo die
Pandemie kam ist dieser Unterschied
wieder da gewesen und Menschen im Osten
haben stärker verschwörungserzählung
geglaubt das zeigt sich für Corona das
zeigt sich für generelle eher abstrakte
verschwörungserzählung und eben auch
jetzt noch mal hier besonders stark das
noch mal stärker als der Unterschied in
Bezug auf Corona und ich denke dass wir
es hier mit einer Mischung zu tun haben
zum einen ja das ist vermutlich noch mal
eine andere Reaktion auf Krisen gibt im
Osten aufgrund auch geographische
Erfahrungen dass eben Dinge sich
komplett handeln können dann auch
natürlich zumindest partiell stärkere
Wahlerfolge der AFD ähm die ja diese
narrative stärker verbreiten und bei den
WählerInnen finden sich diese negative
ja auch noch mal stärker
dann eben aber auch durchaus einen
stärkeren Anti-Amerikanismus der ja auch
in der DDR Teil der Politik der
staatsbüro war dass eben die USA als
Feindbild galt und damit meine ich jetzt
nicht eine Kritik die ist natürlich
komplett legitim aber das ist eben die
USA zum Feindbild wurde das gibt es am
besten natürlich auch aber das ist im
Osten noch mal stärker
von da werde ich reich ihnen zu dieser
aus zu dieser Arbeit und auch zu diesen
Studienergebnissen einen Kommentar
weiter von auf Facebook von Konstantin
Huber er sagt verschwörungsmythen müssen
es noch viel schwerer haben verbreitet
zu werden und das richtet sich jetzt an
sie vielen Dank für die tolle Arbeit von
Pierre lamberti und ihren Kolleginnen
bei Zimmers das soweit dazu wir blicken
aber auch auf die zweite Grafik und
schauen da noch mal auf die
Unterschiedlichkeit bei den Parteien
wenn wir uns da diese Aussage noch mal
vornehmen dann sieht man das aus
aufgeschlüssel nach Partei Anhängern so
da fällt auf das unter den Anhängern von
der AFD und auch der Linken deutlich
mehr Zustimmung zu finden ist als bei
den anderen Parteien die werden da jetzt
gerade noch weiter eingeblendet voller
Berti während wir sehen dass die Grafik
sich noch aufbaut warum ist das so
heißt das Amigo home der die USA werden
für alles verantwortlich gemacht das
heißt das ist schon mal auch Teil der
narrative der AFD die dann halt auch
irgendwann bei den WählerInnen verfangen
und ja auf der anderen Seite wie gesagt
dieser
Anti-Amerikanismus
antinato
Haltungen und das ist ja auch erstmal an
sich legitim der NATO kritisch gegenüber
zu stehen in den USA kritisch gegenüber
zu stehen in einem Arbeitsfeld gehört
dazu wenn man sich auch mit Trump
auseinandersetzt aber das sind trotzdem
noch mal andere Dinge das ist wirklich
so eine feindselige Haltung dann wird
zum Beispiel Menschen in den USA Kultur
abgesprochen
und zwar oder dass man eben sagt ne die
haben keine Ahnung und solche Haltungen
und das geht dann eben ganz häufig auch
mit einer Romantisierung von Russland
eine her dass dann eben sich auch nach
einem starken Führer gesehen wird das so
eine das natürlich natürlich das
ursprüngliche Russland vs das künstliche
Amerika und das ist dann teilweise auch
ein Türöffner in den antisem
itismus schauen wir noch auf eine
weitere Aussage auf eine weitere
verschwörungsmythos den sie rausgefunden
haben da geht es um folgende Aussage
Putin geht gegen eine globale Elite vor
die im Hintergrund die Fäden zieht da am
18 Prozent der Aussage zugestimmt 26
Prozent teils teils und 56% haben das
abgelehnt auch da noch mal der
Unterschied zwischen Ost und West da
sehen wir die Zahlen eingeblendet im
Osten auch da der Anteil wieder höher
der Zustimmung als im Westen wenn wir da
jetzt noch mal Frau lamberti zu unserer
anfangs Erkenntnis kommt das
verschwörungsmythen in Deutschland immer
mehr geglaubt werden im Vergleich zum
April dieses Jahres jetzt haben wir
November hat das dann mit den Propaganda
Instrumenten mit deren Wirksamkeit zu
tun oder gibt es auch noch andere Gründe
die sie sehen
also meine Antwort wäre es ist wichtig
sich mit russischer Propaganda
auseinanderzusetzen zu verstehen dass es
da wirklich Kampagnen gibt einmal direkt
vom Kreml gesteuert aber auch von ganz
vielen
jawilligen Helfern wenn wir uns jetzt
zum Beispiel Leute wie Alina Lippe
anschauen die eben diese negative noch
mal die Gesellschaft tragen aber es
würde davor waren dass nur als Problem
von außen zu betrachten das passiert
auch manchmal wenn man über das
Information spricht das ist so
Externalisierung Strategien gibt das hat
auch was mit unseren demokratischen
Gesellschaft zu tun dass diese Aussagen
so auch im Boden fallen und ich finde
wie gesagt gerade diese Aussage diese
gerade eingeblendet hatte das ist
wirklich auch ein Einfallstor in den
Antisemitismus diese Idee das ist eine
globale Elite gäbe die im Hintergrund
das ist etwas das ganz häufig eben im
Antisemitismus endet und bei dem man
wirklich genau hinschauen soll
dann wichtig dass wir jetzt dazu kommen
dass man eben nicht in dieser
Einfallstore zu eben zum Beispiel wie
sie sagen Antisemitismus verfällt wie
können wir uns davor schützen vor diesen
narrativen wenn sie uns zum Beispiel
auch im Alltag begegnen wenn Fake News
auf in die whatsapp-gruppen gespült
werden wenn es vielleicht sogar mal auch
am Familientisch diskutiert wird also
was gibt es dafür Maßnahmen um sich zu
schützen
ich denke was wichtig ist ist gerade in
unruhigen Zeiten in unsicheren Momenten
erstmal Ruhe zu bewahren also wenn ich
jetzt
zwei Tage zurückblicke
als es eben die Explosion in Polen gab
dann sah man die sozialen Medien waren
voll von Gerüchten von Spekulation zu
dem Zeitpunkt war eigentlich die meisten
Menschen noch gar nicht wussten was
passiert da eigentlich wie ist die
Faktenlage und was bedeutet das also wer
kennt sich tatsächlich
fünf bedeutet ich glaube das sind sehr
sehr wenige und in so einem Moment
auszuhalten dass man gerade ganz wenig
weiß ist schon mal ganz guter Schritt
und zu reflektieren dass man selber auch
anfällig ist das ist nicht nur die
anderen sind die falsche Dinge glauben
sondern dass man auch mal selber auf dem
falschen Fuß erwischt werden kann ist
auch schon ein guter Schutz es gibt da
auch pädagogische Maßnahmen es gibt auch
gerade so ja kleine Spiele die man
digital spielen kann von gemeinnützigen
Initiativen die einem noch mal
Strategien mit an die Hand geben um das
besser zu erkennen das ist so ein fünf
Minuten Pausenfüller aber sich da
wirklich vorzubereiten das bewusst zu
machen das finde ich immer ganz wichtig
ja und wichtig wahrscheinlich auch dann
über diese Unsicherheiten und Themen
dann auch mit anderen zu sprechen und zu
kommunizieren oder
das ja aber die Frage ist natürlich
immer was ist denn der Ort also ich habe
natürlich dann in dem Moment auch Fragen
aber muss ich das öffentlich diskutieren
zum Beispiel auf Twitter oder in
Facebook oder kann ich vielleicht auch
sagen ich habe eine gute Freunde oder
meine Eltern oder Menschen bei denen ich
das Gefühl habe den ich vertraue und
bespreche das erstmal da dass das halt
sich nicht noch verbreitet und noch mehr
Gerüchte gestreut werden von Menschen
die vielleicht auch gar nicht so viel
Hintergrundwissen
ja absolut vielen Dank für diese
Maßnahmen für diesen Ausblick und für
ihre Zeit hier bei ZDF heute live Pia
lamberti vom Center für Monitoring
Analyse und Strategie kurz CMS vielen
dank ihnen danke schön
das war es von uns von unserem Stream
wie Russlands Propaganda in Deutschland
wirkt und wie man sich auch dagegen
schützen kann vielen Dank fürs zuschauen
und bis zum nächsten Mal ciao